And we're rolling in.
Cheers.
That's,
that's only part of a cat lady.
I mean obviously the one,
well it's a critical part.
It is.
Without the red wine.
The Cat lady is not that ridiculous.
Right.
It's just red wine,
Tequila and red bull.
Yeah.
That's normal.
I mean that's like red bull and vodka.
It's not too crazy.
Yeah.
You pour the red wine in there and you're like,
well now you're desperate.
Now you're just like everyone shows up to a party with what they found in their
parents' frigerator.
Yeah.
And then the Cat lady appears.
Have you ever made one of those since then?
Yeah,
a lot.
I
turned people onto it all the time that it was so ridiculous.
I've gone into bars where people recognize me and then they,
the waitress comes over and says,
the bartender would like to give you this cat lady.
And I'm like,
what?
People don't know what we're talking about.
The Cat lady was a drunk,
but John invented two years ago in Lanai.
Two years ago.
Yeah.
I think it was two years ago.
Last year.
The year before that,
two years ago.
And it w it was Shane Dorian,
Sam halt,
Ben O'brien.
John Remy Remi.
Yeah.
He didn't get to enjoy it and that was the first we did a podcast in my suite
and we just went into the mini bar and we just grabbed everything.
I don't know about this we stuff you came with a full bear hug of just I could
hear cling happening and needed has dropped it the middle of the table.
This is what we got.
We like,
hey,
let's podcasts.
And that's where it all started by the fund.
By the end I just was kind of grabbing,
I think I was consuming more than most.
So I was just reaching around trying to take whatever was left.
And then you're like,
what the hell are you boring?
So that was our first year doing this trip.
And uh,
this year was our third and Ma'am is,
it is an honor,
first of all,
it's an awesome place to get ready for like elk to get ready,
get ready for anything.
Yeah.
Anything.
If you can successfully,
especially if someone's walking in no.
Like where they rate.
I remember last year when I l counted with Andy,
I told Andy when we were in Montana that this time I'm going to be limited on
how much I can hunt with you.
Like we'll both go opposite directions.
And then after I think two days and he said,
okay,
I realize now how much of my success before was hinting on you navigating me in
these like small moments that I didn't really realize how important they were.
And I think if you can come here and if you can,
do you like if your guide can get you close,
but then you just say,
I'm going to test only myself from here in like from the 250 yard mark in.
If you can get it done on an axis here,
you can get anything done.
Yeah.
That's great.
Learning skills.
Yeah.
I think that's black belts skills,
especially if you're taking a large,
long shot.
And he managed to crawl into place because a lot of it is crawling.
If you plan on coming out here,
folks bring some kneepads.
Luckily our Sitka gear,
uh,
pants have built in knee pads,
which are excellent.
But if you,
if you,
if you use a different kind of Cammo,
first of all,
you shouldn't,
second of all,
if you do use a different kinds of chemo,
better get some knee pads.
Just the pattern itself looked amazing.
Amazing.
Like when we were glassing across,
when I would glass and look at you,
or when I'd look back,
you blend it.
I mean it worked really well.
It was straight everywhere.
The subalpine is the bomb.
It's the bomb.
I've used a lot of different cammo trying different stuff out and you know,
I really love first light.
They make good stuff.
Um,
but sit cause the best,
they're the best.
They just take everything above and beyond everything is one step better.
Yeah,
it was funny.
They won't,
they won't come out and publicly say that subalpine is effective for like white
tail or Turkeys because the Gore,
the Gore methodology,
uh,
I don't know if I said that right,
but they have a protocol of having their tests to prove things or be able to
make a statement or very vigorous for Gore.
So because they've never truly tested subalpine to a turkeys vision,
they won't come out and publicly say that it's effective for Turkeys.
Even though I can tell you it definitely is early season white tails and midway
through the season for white tails,
hundred percent effective.
But what it was truly tested for was sub Alpine.
It was like tested for hunting big game.
And so they'll say that.
But I can tell you if there's any type of foliage that has a hint of green in
it,
it is effective.
It just breaks everything up.
So good.
Like when we were a Utah hunting elk,
gosh,
lend right.
And I went back a few times and I could I,
I couldn't tell where you were in the,
even in those poplars where there's some white and black speckle.
It looked amazing.
Yeah.
It's a perfect breakup pattern.
You just,
you don't see the,
the,
the human form for here,
what matters most is movement and I guess what the environment.
Ha Ha.
Now we have a something a little different Margarita.
Yup.
That'll work.
Yeah.
The movement is big,
but I became an even bigger believer in the Hex who was here when we had that
bird fly by and just land right behind us.
I was like,
dude,
what is wrong with this bird?
He was right in our idea.
We were there.
Yeah,
he's right in our business.
We were just sitting there,
sit in
there and this bird just flew by and right next to us
and start tweeting away,
letting us know.
I think you said you go,
what's this thing doing?
And I just looked at you.
I'm like,
that's what things do at the heck.
Squirrels jump on my shoulders.
Birds like try to land on me.
What a wig you out is when owls,
when I'm in a whitetail,
Stan and owls will come in and be like cupped gonna land on your shoulder.
If it's a small bird,
I'll let them do it.
If it's a squirrel,
I'm like,
get on there dude,
I'll,
I'll do that when it's got talents.
I'm like,
whoa,
like back off bro.
But I've had several outages Kinda come flying in.
They Cup up and they're just going to land on my shoulder and I,
I have to just whip out just the hex.
Who for people who don't know,
h e c s the heck suit breaks up.
It blocks your electrical signal,
right?
The electromagnetic signal that your body gives off.
Yup.
And it's been proven to work on fish and it's been proven to work on what other
animals fishes tested.
For sure.
Birds for sure.
Because migratory birds have had tons of tons of like,
I think I shouldn't say federal,
but like granted tests to track migratory birds and how they see,
and it's proven that birds do see in electronic fields.
So for birds they say that it's incredibly effective because like that's why
they've got all that footage.
Being able to crawl out on keys and people shooting Turkeys from just sitting
next to nothing,
just you know,
being able to do it.
But for those it's really important that your hands and your face mask and
everything are fully covered with the hex where honestly I'm going with the
major muscle groups for my stuff,
I wear the top and the bottom for small game in big game and I'm a believer man.
Skulls still skeptical though.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
some people say,
hey,
you know,
it seems like you're selling snake oil.
And I'm like,
I get it.
You know,
I understand what you're saying.
All I can tell you tell you is like with bears,
they're predatory animals.
With bears,
my encounters with them has just been weird.
You know how well it works.
But then if my camera guy doesn't have it,
it seems like I'm picked off more.
So I definitely feel like when I've been in my one on one situations and I'm
fully,
you know,
fully clothed in it,
I wear it all the time.
I mean I guess it'd be easy for me to not to,
but I always do.
I mean I,
I'm a believer in it for sure.
Yeah.
I became more of a believer this trip.
I felt like there was too many moments to where deer was staring at us and they
just didn't know what the hell we were when,
whereas like some of the times in the past when I wasn't wearing it,
the same sort of situation to deal would start blowing and then they would take
our,
the baby take off.
Yeah.
Make that crazy barking noise and I took off when you,
when we got up to your deer and where are we?
You know,
we're kind of his final resting place where we took pictures and stuff.
Did you ever look back to the tree that we were,
for those of you who want to know,
we're actually on our flight back.
This is a flight podcast.
Everyone around is like,
what's going on?
Not,
nope,
we're just podcasting folks.
Um,
did you look back at that tree and see how small that tree really was?
Three small,
I've imagined,
me and Joe Rogan tucked up next to kind of a bonds I tree
and we had a crawl about 80 90 yards to get to 80 or 90 yards crawling and we
get to this tree and I,
I kind of grabbed the base of the tree and I'm trying to Shimmy up the tree just
enough and I figured there was going to be a few access there.
And that's the thing with access when they're bedded you might see one or two
that standing up at the time,
but once I got there I look back at you and I'm like giving the signal like
dude,
like don't crawl but like on your belly scoot,
like just use your fingertips in your nails and like pull yourself to me cause
we the f the,
our cover was probably only two feet tall.
And with you with a backpack on,
that was about all you could spare was just laying flat to your stomach and
crawl up to me.
And then you got behind me and used me as a blocker to come up and how many
deer,
how many dearer within 80 yards of us.
It was a lot.
It was a lie.
They were everywhere.
Shot the deer.
That's when we really realize how many there were.
Oh Gee.
Lot of them popped up.
Yeah,
tons.
It was pretty crazy.
So let's talk about your shot first because that was honestly,
that was the highlight of the whole trip for me was just hearing that sound.
We had the sun hearted are back.
I couldn't really see,
I was trying to film so I couldn't really see where your Arrow went.
I just could see,
I could see that broad head right past my shoulder.
And I was looking at the tip of your broadhead and seeing how still it was.
I was like referencing it on something that was behind it and you are just
stable and I could see your broadhead coming back,
back,
back on the rest.
So I knew you're just pulling on that silver back.
Just slow,
slow and sweet.
And as soon as I heard it go dear,
I just looked right at the axis and I heard that sound that just I knew it had
found the honey spot.
Well,
I committed 100% to the silver back last year when,
um,
when a hunted here I was using,
I was using a thumb trigger
and which is great,
but these deers so skiddish and these moments are so,
so adrenaline filled.
I felt like I made a decision.
I'm like,
look,
I shoot super accurate with the silverback.
Why won't I hunt with it?
Like what am I thinking?
Am I thinking that I need to make it go off quick?
I'm just going to go to 100% silver back and I'm super glad that I did because a
shot my uh,
elk last year in Utah with a silver back,
I shot that amazing elk at to hone ranch,
which is like the furthest I've ever shot an animal,
75 yards,
perfect shot in the heart,
silverback.
I practice with a silver back on practice with anything else.
Sometimes I'll practice with the knock to it,
but I use a silver back so much.
I don't even think about punching the trigger,
don't even think about it.
I just put my thumb there and I pull through it the same way I do with it with
the silver bag.
That's how it is.
People don't realize that there's this window when you have one thing that you
really like and you feel comfortable with and you feel like you have control
over,
which let's just say it's the knock to it or,
or an index finger,
wrist strap release,
and then yeah,
you learn with the silver back and you realize,
okay,
this is a good training aid and you're kind of afraid to lose that last little
bit of control that you have.
But there's that window that if you can push through that,
you forget about that feeling and you just realize this is like,
you almost realize there is no other option.
This is just what I shoot with.
Yeah.
This is all I use every day.
Plus I can make it go off in a second or two seconds.
Once you learn it.
Right.
It's all in.
It's all in the scapula.
That's all in that preload.
Yeah,
it's all in that muscle in the middle of the back,
the Rhomboids,
that's,
it's all in that and I shoot with it so much.
You know I,
I have that archery range up my studio and I'm just constantly shooting.
I get there before work or shoot after work,
I shoot her just constantly shooting,
constantly shooting with that thing so my body knows exactly what to do.
That was one of the most satisfying things about this trip.
Like even the shots that I missed and I missed a couple shots because these
animals are so fast and we took some,
you know,
long shots and one of them was 80 something yards and the Arrow was perfectly on
track for the boiler room.
Things saw the Arrow or her,
the Arrow and just like see ya there so fast.
The one thing that's different with the access is I don't think access,
try to locate a sound and then decide whether or not that sound is dangerous or
not.
With most animals,
what I found is the first reaction is to pinpoint where a foreign sound came
from and once they're locked onto that,
if there's anything following that,
then now they,
they kind of react like a fight or flight thing.
So I've had,
I can see this a lot in video footage like with elk were they'll hear the bow
and they'll turn and look to wear a bow went off,
but if they don't hear something coming,
they just stand there and the Arrow comes in.
And I really feel like that with,
with the four fletch setups we have,
I feel like the arrows are quieter than what we shot in the past.
Personally,
we'll definitely want to shot last year because last year here I was trying to
use a fixed played and it was a fixed blade with some holes in it.
Yeah,
it was like a whistle of death
show on some of those longer shots that the deer would turn.
But you could see them look up like on the footage.
Yeah.
These,
they didn't do that.
They just looked our way.
They never looked up to like that sound that they could hear coming in.
So that's why I think the,
the projectile was good,
but these things are just,
they're keyed in and we talked to,
uh,
our buddies,
a Sloan from Yeti and Cole Kramer,
we're over on the main island hunting access to their,
on Maui.
Oh yeah.
They're on Maui hunting access.
And I asked them how they were doing and they're like,
dude,
shot a few.
Dos missed a few,
lost a few.
These sayings are just crazy how fast they react and move.
And you say it's just,
you think it's from tigers,
you think it's evolved to get away from tigers?
It's probably what it is from India.
They were given the King Kamehameha I think in the 18 hundreds but they're just
an insanely fast animal.
There's so much faster.
You'd think of mule deer as being fast.
Like mule deer are drunk and on pills compared to these things.
Really.
They're like,
there's so slow.
I think these are,
these are as fast is a highly pressured south Texas whitetail that's come into a
feeder that's kind of like jumpy twitching the whole time it's there and you
kind of have to aim.
I got to the point where when I was out with Cam,
cam asked me where I am and I said,
dude,
my pin was sitting in the corner pocket of the leg in the body.
Like I literally,
every time I drew back I put my,
the pin I wanted on the back of its front leg.
I followed that back leg up until it touched the bottom of the body and I was
pulling right there.
I was,
I was pulling on my trigger in a place where my pin,
if the Arrow hit exactly behind the pin,
it would've liked just shaved hair off its arm pit,
but that's not where any of the arrows hit.
They were all ducking and turn in and I feel like they're moving at least four
inches down,
possibly more and turning away.
It seems like they duck and spin out like that's their move.
Pick the feet up and like rotate 180 degrees.
You agree?
Yeah,
100% they're never like darting forward.
That's why I think that this is the perfect place to show how effective a rage
is.
The perfect place to show how effective a large cutting surface arrow is.
So broad.
It is.
Yup.
The benefits of it.
Giant,
giant.
If the,
if you,
if you have the variable of not knowing 100% where that Arrow could hit,
you know you're going to be within an area where a kill zone possibly,
depending on how fast it's reacting,
it might be a little bit outside of that.
The more damage the better off you are.
As long as you're able to still get some penetration.
And Cam said too on the last podcast,
he's like,
hey man,
I definitely see where there's an application for this.
Yeah,
he's a fixed bled phene fixed blade fiend.
Do you think you would've got your deer if you would have been shooting a fixed
blade head?
It's hard to say.
I mean,
it's hard to say.
You know,
you,
I think fixed blades,
many of them,
especially vented ones,
they're louder too.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a factor as well.
Yeah.
It could have nothing really knew what had happened with your shot.
I mean,
there was a lot of deer there and it was like Bam.
And then that deer ran off and he knew that thing had to have been completely
expired within
three seconds.
Yeah.
To be fair,
it's sprinted as far as it could get was like 50 yards,
which will,
you see how fast and access runs.
50 yards is not very long and it was dead seconds and,
and,
and done and everything else was just looking around like what happened?
What happened?
Yeah.
I had a second shot.
I tried to get a second shot at another deer at 70 yards.
And that,
that deer duck the string.
Yeah.
Because then they're all alert.
They're all like,
they knew what was up.
You shut the rx three.
Love it.
It's so first it was so quiet.
It's so quiet.
Quiet.
And in Rx one.
Yeah.
Which I loved.
I love the rx one,
but this is better.
I mean those Hoyt engineers,
man,
they know what they're doing.
It's thing is super quiet and super accurate.
Did Cam shoe in our XRD she likes.
Oh,
okay.
That's right.
I forgot which one he was shooting.
I'm,
I shot the helix to,
I'm going to switch back to um,
to an rx three.
I think for elk season.
People ask me all the time why,
you know,
why one over the other?
I like to shoot them all because I know people have different price ranges.
Um,
I don't think one's more accurate than the other.
I really like the fact that I can change my grips out on my,
on the human memorizer.
Yeah.
If I was honest,
I would say I would like it if Hoyt went back to what they used to do on the
carbon risers.
Where did they do that?
They wanted you to be able to have the ability to shift the new grip left or
right depending on how your natural grip is turning the bow so that you can
adjust it to have like perfect alignment of the Arrow down the center shot of
the riser,
uh,
for you.
Because obviously we've been shooting together for years.
You don't have natural torque in your front hand,
so I didn't have to shift it any way.
Your Arrow and everything is lined up right down the pipe.
Like right down the stabilizer.
Your pin sits right on the outside edge of your shaft.
You don't have any torque in the,
in the riser at all.
You don't even need to move it.
But I think some people have a natural ability to kind of grab the handle.
So they wanted you to be able to remove that screw,
lift the grip off,
and you can move this aluminum plate left or right underneath the plastic grip
to kind of compensate for your natural tour.
Personally,
I'd rather just not have the torque.
Yeah,
learn how to not shoot that way.
that's probably best.
Yeah.
It's like a bandaid.
So maybe
love those.
Knock on elk plates.
Yeah,
I loved the way it feels in the hand too.
It's extra grippy.
Even when you're sweaty,
it feels like it really sits in your hand.
Well,
I've always said less.
Less riser in your hand is better,
you know,
less,
less than your hand gives you less ability to torque what you're holding on to.
Is it the same for pool cues?
It depends.
Some people like a thin grip pool cue and uh,
that's what they prefer.
I have big hands and I like a fat grip pool cue because there's less movement in
my hand when I,
when I hold a pool cue,
when it's sitting in my hand,
I want,
I want my hand to be like just dead.
I don't ever want to,
I don't grip the queue.
No.
Like have a death grip.
So your elbow is almost like an upside down pendulum.
My cue sits on like,
you know,
in Spiderman is his web show.
Those two fingers were Spiderman uses.
That's how it goes.
That's how I hold my cue.
My cue sits in those fingers.
And this,
so the idea is that it just like,
you're almost throwing the queue at,
at the,
uh,
at the ball.
So you're throwing the queue at the cue ball so that uh,
you're kind of like letting the weight of the cue and the swing of the arm do
the work.
You're not,
you're not death gripping it and jerking it and punching it.
You don't ever want to punch the cue ball.
You want me,
you want to,
you want to be relaxed.
The whole idea is to be relaxed.
When I'm playing at my very best,
I'm barely gripping the queue and I'm letting the natural texture of the rap sit
in my hand.
And this one of the reasons why a lot of times I like to use a wrap lists queue,
which is just wood with you know,
a,
an enamel or I mean some slacker co cover on it.
And then I put a bees wax on the lacquer and that's my favorite cause just sits
in the hand.
It's tacky and I don't have to grip it at all and I just let the Q do all the
work and it's like the more you can relax in,
the more I play.
Like I play for a few hours,
then I get real relaxed and then I can
really just sorta like gently move my arm and let the cue ball do all what the
acoustic,
move the cue ball and do all the work.
You're the same with archery.
Me,
it's like I can come out of the gate and feel really relaxed and feel effortless
as I shoot and then as I fatigue I obviously feel like I'm putting more effort
in.
When I'm ready to pack up.
You're just starting to loosen up and it's the same with with pool,
you could play pool forever.
I mean I've had to just be like,
hey dude,
I'm done.
Here's like,
I'm just getting loosened up.
Yeah.
I get loosened up about eight hours in
with with pool.
The guys that look like they're not putting any effort in is that when they're
with archery,
one guys look super comfortable.
Like you almost feel like the bow isn't real.
You watch them.
You look at,
I'm at full draw and you realize it doesn't even look like they're holding 60
pounds.
Like they look,
everything is in line,
everything's efficient.
It look effortless.
Is it the same with pool?
Exactly the same.
Yeah.
When you see someone tighten up from nerves,
you see their hand grip,
the Q different,
and you see movement.
You see like the cue cue goes a little bit left little bit,
right.
They've put unnecessary an accidental English on the cue ball.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's one of those things where the more you can stay calm,
the more you can relax and rely on technique.
That's one of the reasons why archery so attractive to me because there's so
many parallels in pool.
So my name and martial arts as well.
One thing you said the other day that I really,
really liked,
and I don't know how we got on the subject,
it might have been yesterday,
but we were talking about,
um,
we're talking about how sometimes in sport for me it's ease.
It always seems easy to forget the basics.
Like I forget and,
and all sudden there'll be coaching someone new or something and I realize
they're asking them this question.
It's like,
oh man.
Yeah,
I'm taken for granted this basic.
Yeah.
But for you,
you said with comedy you never do that,
which I think has to make you better at it because you and actually with my
school of nock what I do to myself every year in December,
every year in December,
I'm like,
okay,
whatever I've done this past year,
doesn't matter.
I'm going to wipe the slate clean.
I'm going to start with shooting enough arrows to where I can,
I can build some stamina practicing and then I'm just going to focus on my
fundamentals one week at a time to try to back up.
It's not as,
it's not going back as far in the basics is I think what you were talking about,
but it's still,
it's still a really cool like training aspect,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Well what we were talking about,
what you're saying is every two years I ride a whole new act and I started,
I'm like a beginner again.
I'm a beginner who knows how to do,
but I don't
have any new material.
My material is,
or I don't have any old material.
My two materials all new,
so I have to figure out how to make it work and all these people are paying to
see me,
so I have to work really hard at it so I can't be lazy and I can't take it for
granted.
And it's like I become almost like a beginner again every two years.
So every year lately because of the Netflix special.
Yeah.
Well it's too,
yeah,
it's,
it's two years in between specials.
Every special,
I did one in 2014 2016 2018 so I'm on like a two year schedule.
It seems to me to be the right way to do it because you can Polish,
yeah,
you can get you.
But what's most important as one that's special comes out.
Like my last one came out in October of last year of 2018 and that specialist
out that materials dead.
It's gone.
You can't say it again.
Then I moved to the new material and then I have to write and I have to,
so I have all these people coming to see me.
So there's no way you're ever relaxed or too comfortable or you can't take it
for granted.
You have to always be nervous and always be on the ball and always be working
hard and always be concentrating on the fundamentals of comedy,
like the making sure that you're using the economy of words,
making sure that you're saying things in a way that makes sense to people.
The best way to get it to people won't sneak in the punchlines where they don't
see him come in and have premises that are good and address those premises in a
way.
It's like the most smooth way to do it and so it requires a lot of thinking
about comedy a lot.
A lot.
It seems like you're in the perfect place to be so close to the store for you to
be able to go to the comedy store.
I mean,
can you think of something that morning and be like,
I want to try this.
I think of things on my way to the comedy store.
Really?
Yeah,
all the time.
And you're like,
I'm just going to throw this out.
That out there.
Yup.
Throw it out there to sink or swim.
Sometimes they sank and you've got to acknowledge it.
You got to let the people know,
all right,
that was a new joke and that sucks.
We're going to keep going.
And then people get a kick out of it because they know that you're trying things
out.
Like all the people that really know comedy.
That's actually one of the beautiful things about the comedy store's.
How many comedy fans like real efficient autos go.
There are people who,
you know,
they know that they can go there on any night of the week.
They could see some of the best headliners on the planet and they know the
process.
They understand.
Particularly one of the beautiful things about podcasts is that through podcasts
,
um,
we talk about it all the time.
We talk about that process.
So the people that listen to my podcast and many other comedians podcast,
they understand our process now where they didn't before.
10 years ago,
people had no idea of Comedians roadshows.
Now they know the people that are really big fans.
They know really well.
I've seen some of your lineups were just,
it happens
to be where those guys go to the store and it's not like it's a lineup.
It could be a fricking comedy.
All Star Math.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I've seen names on that top sign rum,
like Jesus,
if you went there that night,
yeah.
You're like hitting the best of the best.
You could plan it on the planet and it's 20 bucks,
20 bucks.
And you might see Dave Chappelle,
Joey Diaz,
Ari Shaffir,
Thompson Gurra,
Bert Kreischer me.
I mean,
you see crystal Lee,
uh,
you see,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Edwards Smith.
It's just over and over and over.
It's like the lineup isn't saying guys you've never heard of that are murderers.
Yeah.
And I mean,
it's a,
it's a beautiful place.
It's one of the main things that keeps me in La.
Yeah.
For sure.
That in the podcast you have a good routine.
Yeah,
man,
I was ready to go.
I was ready to get the hell out of California a long time ago.
They sucked me in.
Well.
What's cool about our relationship to is
there comes this point about November were you fully switch gears to comedy and
I fully switch gears to product development coming out,
really working on my shooting and I go in this,
I kind of go reclusive as a friend.
There's been,
I think it at Christmas time,
didn't I text you at Christmas?
And I said,
sir,
you know,
sorry for being a bad friend.
You weren't a bad friend.
We both do the same thing.
We're both,
I'm like,
you know,
I just said,
I know you're doing the same,
but like that's from I think as soon as elk season ends you go,
you did start your rewrite and yeah,
you wipe the slate clean and you start polishing and when you're in that,
when you're doing your comedy,
do you have to to stay in there to really,
really do good at it?
That was what was always hard with me when people ask me to do articles is
there's certain times a year where I feel like I can write an article and it's
really me and a lot of times it's when I'm coaching.
When I'm coaching and I'm seeing new people and I'm thinking about these things
or I'm working on people's gear.
I feel like I'm a good writer at that point,
but when someone hits me in the middle of a time where I'm like
in the middle of family vacations or if I'm in the middle of a mountain El Con,
I just feel like I'm,
I'm like,
I'm kind of forcing it.
Is it the same for you?
Yeah.
Get those windows where you're like,
this is my window where I hang out with comics.
I just think about this stuff.
This is where I'm thinking about when I'm working out.
Do you I can never get out of shape.
I got comedy is like,
it's very critical to never really get out of shape like out of shape is like
this whole week I didn't do comedy.
That's as long as I did to me said some fucking shit fun though.
I know.
Yeah,
but I can tell you're always thinking about we,
we bring up subjects,
I can't even think of them,
but a subject would come up and oh that night,
the last night when cam was there and me,
you and cam sat there and then the girls finally came towards the very,
yeah,
we got on some subjects.
I was just looking around like,
is there anyone here?
I like,
hopefully like we have some privacy because we went down some rabbit holes man.
But it was funny.
Well that's the
beautiful thing about comedy.
You know,
it's like everybody knows there's some subjects that you can't really bring up
around a lot of people and those are the ones I liked the most.
You know?
Those are the ones that like if I can sell those to thousands of people,
if I'm in a room and there's seven thousand ten thousand people in the audience
and I can sell this soup or fucking dangerous idea.
Sometimes I say,
I'm like,
hear me out.
Yeah,
like Jesus Christ,
what are you saying?
But if you,
if you have a point and it's well thought out,
it's like they really appreciate that you took that crazy ass chance and then
they're laughing with you.
Like,
I can't believe,
like I did a show.
Um,
uh,
last week,
we were in Chicago and I did this giant arena and Daniel Cormier,
who's never seen me do stand up before came and afterwards we're working
together doing commentary in the next day he grabbed it.
He's like,
yeah,
can't believe this shit.
You were getting away with me either.
Dude.
It's funny,
but it's like you gotta know that you have a point.
You've got,
you got to really have that,
but you can't just say it for shock value.
Like for me,
especially at this stage in my career,
I'm in this very unusual,
uh,
stratosphere.
There's not that many people that are in the first place.
I would argue that you are in the stratosphere of your own dude.
You're at the top of this needle where you get away with shit that no one on
this planet can get away with.
I don't know about that.
I think maybe other people would get away with it if they thought that about the
things that I was,
I did about this.
You gotta you gotta have this,
I think about things a lot before I say him.
I mean it's not like I'm just flippantly saying something that might hurt
someone's feelings or piss somebody off.
Like I want to make sure I cover those bases.
You almost cover everyone's opinion within that arena and you've got to start
off with the people that are opposing you.
Yep.
You got to start off looking at it like from the,
you bait them in.
Yeah,
I've been there.
I've been there at times where I'm like,
okay,
he's wanting them to like him just for a minute cause he's getting ready to shit
on them.
I just learned them into a trap of logic.
Yesterday I'm here.
Yesterday we were at the hotel and I'm walking around with my Vegan cat shirt
and uh,
I have,
I told you a story.
I was at a,
I was in our Iowa and someone came up to me and they were legitimately,
it was a lady and she was legitimately triggered and she just said,
do you kill cats?
Because I had the shirt,
that's one of Joe's shirt that has a cat with two x's on his eyes.
And it just says,
Hashtag yeah,
if cartooned out when cartoon animals would be dead,
they would have x's for eyeballs.
So it was Hashtag Vegan cat,
which is,
you know,
obviously one of the parts of Djogan Joe's Netflix special from last year.
But,
uh,
I'll just looked at her and I said,
no.
I said,
I love cats.
And I said,
I'm trying to raise awareness for people that are feeding their cats like a
vegan and they're causing blindness in felines.
And she goes,
what?
And I said,
yeah,
people quit feeding their cats meat and they become blind.
And I said,
I'm trying to raise awareness.
And she's like,
oh my God,
I had no idea.
Thank you so much.
I'm going to start to raise awareness to people were still yesterday when I was,
uh,
yesterday I went to uh,
to get a drink at the bar and the girl that came over and surgery,
she stopped me yesterday and she goes,
do you hate cats?
And I go,
why?
And she goes,
what does that shirt mean?
I hope it's nice.
And I said,
yeah,
it's totally nice.
And she goes,
great,
I'm a Vegan and I love cats.
And I'm like,
well we're friends.
But yeah,
that's one of the subjects right there.
That's one of the subjects where you got away with it.
Dude.
No one else could get away with it.
That one was,
that one was a lot of work.
That was a lot of work.
That one I had to like circumnavigate that terrain many times to figure out the
right way to get that bit across cause that was a real thing that did happen.
A lady really did say a bunch of mean stuff to me.
And then I went to her account and it said Hashtag Vegan Kat.
And I really did look at my watch and go,
shit,
should I look at this like I should go to bed right now.
And I know this is true because most of the time when Joe texts me something
that's,
it's within 30 minutes.
And when I wake up in the morning,
cause with the two hour difference you're going to bed around three 30 and I'm
getting up around like four,
four 30 and why do you mind my best
writing?
Whatever reason,
late at night.
And I think part of it's cause my wife and my kids are asleep and I'm usually
coming home from the comedy store.
So I work,
I do my sets and then I come home and then I write a lot of good time to do it.
Yeah.
Cause everyone's asleep and my brain's fired up.
So usually I'm just hanging out with the dog and just writing and then like
right until it was too sleepy.
And then I go to sleep.
But sometimes like I'll get these sparks.
So I'm like,
I'm like,
uh,
I'm a spark farmer.
I'm out there.
And just trying to farm some sparks or a forage or for sparks.
I'm looking for sparks and then I find a spot
I below on that spark and I try to turn it into a flame and then I have to keep
that flame alive.
And so then I have to keep working at it on stage and figuring out a way and
then some people booed me or they'll get mad at me and I go to that.
That's what I'm saying.
And then I have to figure out,
okay,
how do I stop the BU in its tracks?
Well I've got to get to their argument before they do.
Yeah.
So I have to figure out a way in such a good way to approach it dude.
But it's like if you're crafty,
this sneaky.
Yeah.
It's obvious you're a black belt in Jujitsu person cause you're baiting people,
sneaking them in.
Yeah.
You up and son of a bitch once.
You are one of those things where it's like I've been doing it now for more than
30 years.
It'll be 31 years this August.
So it was crazy.
I'm trying to remember.
I remember you doing a show,
I don't know if he did a show at the Riviera,
but I was shooting in Vegas and I know it was late nineties,
early two thousands and you were doing a show there.
Yeah,
yeah.
I used to do shows there.
That was the only place I performed in Vegas was it?
Was it at Riviera?
Yeah,
I remember it then.
Yeah.
So that would have been,
I'm sure it's 20 years ago.
So you'd have been 10 years in.
Yep.
And I think I remember,
uh,
I remember some of my friends go on and they were shocked
because they said they're like,
he is not filtered in his comedy compared to how he announces the UFC.
Because you like I,
there's no subjects off limits.
Is there a UFC is a different job.
You know,
it's,
it's very confusing for people and I kind of sympathize with them because I have
two completely unrelated jobs like comp,
well almost three because podcasting is sometimes funny,
but many times not like sometimes I'm just talking to scientists and then
sometimes I'm talking to scholars or the diversity is what has people hooked.
But it's,
to me,
it's,
that's how I view the world.
I don't need to be funny.
Like I don't ever try to be funny when I'm doing the UFC mom,
when my obligation,
when I'm doing the UFC is to give justice or to give,
uh,
to,
to honor the hard work that these men and women have put into and their training
camp and to appreciate their effort and to appreciate their art.
The martial art.
You're super serious about martial arts hit when people try to make that funny.
You don't like it?
No.
Most of the time I don't.
I mean,
unless something funny happens.
Yeah.
But it has to be my balls are hot.
If something like that.
Yeah.
That's just genuinely funny.
I'll laugh at that.
But for the most part,
my job is to make it exciting for people that are listening and to sort of
explain what's happening in terms of particularly the ground.
Like people kind of understand when someone's throwing a kick or a punch and
it's my job to point things out that I see like patterns.
Sometimes I'll see like someone moving,
I'm like,
this guy is moving at a much higher level in an off.
Sometimes that happens right before I got to gets knocked out.
I'll say I see a bit like this this past weekend.
Um,
Ricardo Lamas was fighting Calvin cater and uh,
I said,
I see a big difference between the striking level of Calvin cater and Ricardo
Lamas.
Calvin is just boom,
he lands a knockout blow.
Like right after I said that.
Like sometimes it's crazy.
Yeah,
it happens like that.
But you,
but that's important for,
for people at home.
Like they want,
they do the one,
the one of the reasons why some people like me as a commentators,
cause they know that I'm,
I genuinely enjoy this.
This is not a job to me is something I don't think,
oh here I am working,
I'm getting paid,
I'm getting some money.
I don't think of that.
But I think is like I am,
first of all,
I love the sport I and I genuinely appreciate what these guys are doing are
these girls are doing and I just want to give,
I want to honor what they're doing.
I think anything you have interest in you a 100% come across as authentic.
And that's what,
that's what people say they like about me is because they say,
I feel like you are a 100% authentic about your passion for archery.
Yeah.
And honestly I feel like social media helps accelerate that because people start
to not have only this filter that the TV network allows people to see or that
sometimes you are,
I don't have control on what that filter is.
We might say like,
hey man,
that's not me.
Can you like I really like if you did it like this or like no,
you know,
we've done some polls and this is really what we want.
Which is what,
which is why I left my network because I realized if I go onto a live feed
people a hundred percent get exactly how I feel.
Yeah.
And I think the more that they experience that their radars of people's natural
radars of who's legit and who's not there.
Yeah.
And
I think it's the,
it's the best thing in the world for people like me or you or cam or any of
these people that we know within their fields where there they're real,
they're real people within those fields.
Or aunt,
you know,
Andy's a great example too.
He's like,
he's almost breaking the mold of what a lot of navy seals are doing.
Is it fair to say that because so many,
so many like ride their past to,
you know,
to try to,
build something,
whereas Andy's almost,
you almost have to drag it out of them.
You know,
you almost have to say like,
no dude,
you've done some really cool shit.
We need to talk about this.
And he's trying to say,
well,
there's more to me than that.
You know,
But I think once people really see that honesty come forward,
that's what people are grasping for.
They're like,
I really want,
I really liked that person that I'm seeing.
That's what I want more of.
Yeah.
You're not produced,
you know when someone wants it.
That's a good way to put back on when you're doing a live stream or whether
you're doing a podcast,
you're not produced.
And that's the same with me.
I don't have anyone telling me to do.
And I've been in that situation where I had someone telling me to do and it
tells me what to do or what to say.
And it's,
it's just,
it's not as effective.
It's not as genuine.
It doesn't come across that way.
Yep.
I saw today.
It's fun.
It's weird how your phone,
your phone's a spy.
I got today,
I got ads pulled up in my Instagram about travel coolers.
Whoa.
Cause we were talking about coolers.
Yeah.
Last night at dinner we were going to get our meat home.
Isn't that crazy,
isn't it?
It's so weird.
It's crazy.
Crazy.
So it's listening to us.
It's listening for sure.
Yeah.
It's those who can tell us what's happening.
I want to know like what is your,
I need to get someone on that tells me what the hell you're phone is listening
to.
Cause that does happen to be all the time.
We're all of a sudden the Google feed news feed has ads.
If that happens where you get really high before they come on,
just so you can really study where she can really trip out because you'll be
like,
whoa.
Yeah,
you'll be deep into that need to find out.
I need to find out how they're doing it and what they're doing.
Cause that's weird.
Like what if you're like planning a murder,
you know your phone on you and then also have FCI knocks on your door and I've
done or no,
I'm writing a book on murder and I'm planning it out with a friend to try to
pretend that we are planning a murder.
So I could see how people talk when they're planning a murder.
So me and my,
that's a cover up there.
But if you did do that,
imagine if you did do that.
Like if you were like Jack Carr,
right?
Our friend George Peterson who,
uh,
he just gave me these two new books.
I brought mine here,
read it.
But we were,
we never had downtime that we were having fun the whole time.
But like you say,
Jack was writing a book or George was writing a book and he was trying to figure
out how jack is is a,
we should say is,
is his pseudonym that he uses for writing check cars is,
yeah,
it's his pen name is nom de Plume.
Um,
but if he was trying to figure out how someone would talk when they were setting
up a murder and so he got together with an actor or,
or,
or a detective or someone and said,
how w what would you say?
Like how would you talk about it?
What would you do?
What would be the steps?
And the phone picked that up and all of a sudden the FBI's knocking on his door
and say,
Hey,
I'm not murdering anybody.
I'm writing books.
Like,
what are we doing here folks?
What if you've got an ad for like ballet latex gloves,
bleed shaped,
climbed a shovel,
a 1987,
18 minivan gasoline,
gasoline lighters and be like,
hmm.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm sure,
honestly,
I'm sure there's companies that would pay if they knew this guy is a buyer.
Oh yeah,
he's sketchy.
We don't care.
We're just trying to make money.
We don't know nothing.
Yeah.
I think that,
um,
you know,
we're talking about to get away from that we were talking about when it comes to
honesty,
there's never really been,
uh,
shows where no one was telling anyone what to do.
There's never been like,
you think about how many downloads you get per episode like theirs.
That's what you get for your archery podcast is like a successful cable show,
which is really crazy.
Yeah.
Right.
Think about it.
More downloads in two days on my podcast than what Friday night full draw at
eight o'clock on the sportsmans channel got when I had that slot,
I couldn't,
uh,
I,
I would only imagine that they can't compete.
No.
Cause it's no way all watered down and it doesn't resonate with people the same
way.
When people know that straight from your mouth and there's no one,
oh this is who John Dudley really is.
Like one of the things that people tell me when they meet me,
they go,
oh,
you're like,
hey,
how are you on the podcast?
[inaudible] and again that's me.
They just,
I don't have a boss,
but there's never been a thing like that when you don't have a boss.
And yet every episode reaches millions and millions of people.
Like if I could see the number of people,
if I could like be on a stage and look out and see like I had a be real from
Cypress Hill on the podcast the other day.
That was a good one.
Amazing.
I love that guy.
I love him.
I love Cypress Hill.
But he,
we showed video footage of when they're playing at Woodstock and that was a half
a million people.
Well if I have a half a million people listen to a podcast,
that podcast sucked.
Like something must've went wrong.
So think about the numbers like for a podcast that's like a killer podcast.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's unbelievable.
Yeah.
What were,
I mean,
if you think back of like a really good band that sold out a stadium,
what that number would be in there?
Like this is a legitimate successful band.
Well,
I feel like,
uh,
a really big giant band can do like a football stadium,
50,000 people or 70,000 people,
which is,
you know,
unheard of.
Right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Those are giant,
giant numbers.
But that ain't shit for a podcast.
That ain't shit.
So think about one of your podcasts is way bigger than a football stadium,
which was really nuts,
man.
Yeah,
it's really nuts.
It's never been anything like this and it's free.
It's free.
There's never been anything like this and there's never been anything where have
to be using those sick and iPads for some other purposes back in the day.
Yeah.
You need more than the sick and iPads.
More [inaudible] some,
you know,
some thick ones.
Yeah.
These callused hands wouldn't be favorable.
It's,
um,
it's cool though,
man.
I mean we,
we came at the right time for this.
You know,
we're,
I mean for you to have laugh the sportsmans channel and enter into this new
world.
Isn't it awesome though?
What I think is so cool is,
um,
and we,
me and cam talked about this,
about the number of people that we get exposed to that we would have never got
to hear their voice.
People that write just a super cool book having a,
you know,
that have dedicated their lives to an to an awesome topic.
Yeah.
And you would have never,
like,
unless jre was out there for you to go down some wormhole at three o'clock in
the morning and be like,
you know what,
this dude like,
I gotta get this guy on.
He's,
he's tripping me out with some of this information.
And then you share it to millions and millions and millions of millions.
Yeah.
The,
I mean it makes,
honestly,
it makes mainstream,
it makes it harder for them to lie.
Thanks.
Don't you think makes it harder for them to survive because they seem so corny.
Like you have a,
a mainstream show that covers these subjects.
It's like stupid music and dramatic,
you know,
reads and it's obviously written and they don't get to just talk like to,
to discuss subjects you need time to define or how someone really feels about a
subject.
You need time.
Yeah.
And you know,
and what these shows are trying to do is they're trying to create these gotcha
moments for,
they're trying to catch people and misrepresent their position on things and
they're trying to,
you know,
they're trying to like create controversy cause that's how they sold things in
the past.
But people are getting tired of being bullshitted.
They're getting tired of it.
They want to like,
like when
I had Graham Hancock on the other day,
it was this massively successful podcasts.
Millions and millions of people downloaded it.
And it's about the origins of civilization on earth,
which is such a crazy subject.
Yeah.
I think that so many people would be fascinated by,
but they are,
but they were never represented before because it was never given to them in a
way where you could just listen to the author who was this incredibly well
researched guy,
incredibly articulate,
has been passionate about the subject for decades,
and who is also often maligned by mainstream archeologists and scholars,
and now they'll,
those mainstream archeologists and scholars through new evidence and new
discoveries have been forced to recognize that human beings have existed in
these,
these more advanced civilizations in ever we than anyone ever thought before.
For many,
many,
many years,
thousands of years prior to when we had dated organized civilizations and
cultures,
and it wasn't that these subjects were an interesting before.
It's just that you didn't get a chance to listen to someone talk about it.
No.
It stop without an interruption or without a producer saying,
you know what?
That part was an interesting,
right.
Now there's gaps or you leave someone the ability to intervene and say,
well,
no,
that's not accurate because he never mentioned this because I actually had,
but they edited it out.
Yeah,
that'd be the person that'd be on like a PBS special.
And you're at the mercy of when the error yeah.
How they break it up into their 22 minutes and it doesn't,
it doesn't give it the justice that,
you know,
obviously someone that's dedicated that much time where it deserved.
Yeah,
no,
it's um,
it's a new world and you and I got super lucky that we kind of stumbled into
this new world,
you know,
and,
uh,
I was listening to your podcast,
longform met you and,
uh,
why I watch your TV show and then I found out about your podcast and then I was
listened to your podcast and I was saying how crazy this,
this guy's talking about like x tens and different flood chains and different
configurations and healing goals and all this shit.
Like,
Whoa,
fuck is listening to this.
How can I write that in the 1200 words to kids?
You can't someone be like,
Hey,
we need a feature article.
Right.
1250 cap it out.
But to me it
really,
um,
resembled pool in a way because with pool there's all this talk about low
deflection shafts or 13 millimeter tip versus 12 millimeter,
12 and a half millimeter,
a carbon fiber shafts.
Um,
uh,
maple butts versus uh,
Ebony which is a stiffer,
heavier way.
19 inch sh
balance carbon you told me.
Yeah.
There's Internet for shafts.
A lot of the top top players are using carbon shafts
and like the big name companies,
like a Predator,
they're making carbon shafts for,
for cues.
And a lot of people swear by them.
They don't Ding up like regular ones do.
But it's also like if I started talking to people the way,
I mean I've been playing pool for
20,
25 years.
Yeah,
about 25 years I've been playing pool like pretty,
I mean I never really stopped.
I mean maybe a little bit when I was really getting heavily into video games,
I deviated a bit.
But for 25 years I've been playing pool and experimenting with different tips
and later tips versus buffalo hide tips versus cow high versus pig tips.
Something means is all these different types of just kinds of equipment.
And
You tell them that you saying this right now is probably like when you listen to
one of my first podcast,
I think one of my first podcast or the top few was,
um,
cause I kind of wanted to come out of the gate with,
this is how deep I've gone.
And so I got James Park on,
which I love James.
He's an awesome dude.
He's from Australia,
but this guy could have a doctorate in the aerodynamics of an Arrow.
That's probably one of the ones that tripped you out probably.
But now you're talking pig tips.
Yeah,
the pool cue.
Yeah.
Thinking like it's making sense where I'm like,
well Duh.
Yeah,
different density leather tips when totally makes sense.
But I never even knew it existed until right now.
And now I'm thinking,
Oh shit.
Yeah.
Now I'm thinking,
well there's 50 different types of plastic.
Like how many are they playing with?
Delran then put in the pig to Dick on the top of it.
Are they using for skin yet?
Yeah.
And then there's also wrapped cues versus rap lists.
The way you hold it,
the way you grip it.
Some guys like to grip it with their wrists bent forward so there's less
variation.
Some guys let the,
let the light to let the law Risko real loose and let the,
the cradle,
the Q in their hands.
It's a,
there's all these different techniques and strategies and like it's also like
finger punches,
right?
Some guys who can punch that trigger and they can do it really accurately.
It's very few people.
That's the same thing with guys who have a death grip on the queue.
Some guys have a death grip on the Q line play.
Really?
Now you don't have a death grip,
but you know it's like anything else.
You would have to learn how to do it correctly and you would have to practice.
You know,
I practice playing pool by myself mostly most of the times and I play,
I played by myself.
I wish I could do what ironman does,
where he talks at Jarvis and they expand stuff.
I want to do that on that.
On
your brain when you're looking at angles on a,
yeah,
because you want much when I'll break if I break,
cause Joe and I've played together a couple different times.
You look at the table and I can see like I know you're thinking Joe the when the
thinking Joe's there like all the cogs are turning and you're doing you're rain
man thing.
I wish I knew how many different angles and shit you were looking at.
Well I'll tell you if you want,
you know I'll,
I'll show it to you.
Like we were talking about a little bit the other day.
I was like well I have to go with the four.
I have tinted with righthand English because I have to wind up on the left hand
side of the five cause I want to drift down to the sixth is so close to the
second.
I don't have the seven rather I don't have much room or playing your whole
layout.
I played four balls ahead always.
That's it.
No.
Sometimes I only play three balls ahead if it's like a fairly easy rack but
sometimes I like to play four balls ahead.
They give.
If there's a cluster,
then I know I have to break it out.
I can't,
I can't fuck around.
I have to make sure that I'm on the high side of this ball because when I
collide,
when I make the shot,
I have to hit that second bar.
I will.
I won't be able to get out.
I'm trying to get out.
I'm not trying to just when I want to watch someone play because everybody likes
to say they know how to play pool,
which is hilarious.
People come to my podcast studio,
they're like,
oh,
you play pool.
Let's play some pool.
I knew you well enough to just say,
I don't know shit about further.
When you're like,
do you play pool?
I'm like,
nope.
I don't want to hold this thing,
but I always,
I watch how they make a ball if they just try to make a ball.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
You can't play pool.
You might be a little pockets and balls,
but I'm going to fuck you up in the long run.
You might be able to make all the shots and run out and I'll say,
congratulations,
that was a disaster you got out,
but those terrible,
I did that twice.
It can happen.
Yeah,
it's actually the perfect,
this is the perfect time to talk about when people try to argue with me why?
When they say what I'm doing is work and it's always worked and they're like,
we know you teach that way.
The way that I teach,
I would say 80% of the people,
it maximizes them to the best of their ability.
Are there a fraction of people that are like the exemptions to the rule?
Yeah,
and you can probably go and win a tournament.
You could probably at some point in your career if you go to enough major
events,
you'll win lawn doing it your way,
but I,
I'm certain that what I'm teaching will get the mass,
majority of people more
production over a long run,
there'll be more effective.
Right,
right.
Way To do it.
Is that right?
Is it the same?
Yes.
It's like,
I beat you two games of pool.
But to me that's like,
you know,
if you fricking throw three things out of the window,
one every hundred times is going to land where you think it might land,
but it's just cha,
it's chance.
Well,
playing on a eight
by four,
which is a smaller table and it has buckets for holes.
It's like,
like those buckets,
all those things factor in.
And you know,
the table that I have in my studio is sucks.
It's bad.
That's a brutal table.
That's like one of those metal targets that has the softball size.
Actually what it is shooting at 40 hours.
Every shot.
I'm like,
dude,
I swear I would've made the shot at my old table at home.
And you're like,
yeah,
these pockets are a little smaller.
I'm like,
Dang,
they're an inch and a half shorter than a regulation pocket.
Yeah.
But that's how I,
that's how I practice.
By the way,
the last podcast I did with Joe on the Gre,
uh,
there was a few people that said I might've gone too far on the,
on the drink.
Just so everyone knows.
Joe was beating my ass for about three hours on the pool table,
on the small ass pockets.
So I was just like drinking my sorrows away and about the time he was all warmed
up and it had enough of me said,
let's podcast.
And I'm like,
I thought we were podcasts tomorrow.
He's like,
no,
let's just go now.
So yeah,
that,
yeah,
that was a rough one.
You didn't win a single game that time.
That was rough.
That fucking table is rough,
man.
That table's rough.
It was,
but that's my practice table.
That's how I like,
it's like putting that um,
uh,
outdoorsman,
atlas pack running up,
taking you right to the TAC and be like,
all right.
Yeah,
yeah.
120 yards.
Hit that sheep.
Yup.
37 degree angle.
Good luck.
Know Finder.
Exactly.
Hope that,
hope you've learned some stuff.
It's a,
you know,
there's levels,
there's levels to everything.
And one of the things that I learned very early on when I became obsessed with
martial arts was how important technique is to generate power,
to generate real power and to be,
to do things correctly.
Can you name one field where that's not important?
I can principles,
no,
I can't comedy.
It's with everything.
Like Joey Diaz,
when you see Joey on stage,
he's so wild and crazy and his comedy is so,
it's so out there.
You think may be,
there's no technique to it,
but he's one of the best technicians.
He knows exactly what exactly what he's doing does,
but he's such an amazing technician because he has the best economy of words.
Like,
here's a Joey Diaz joke that I love.
He goes,
I like transvestites.
They Cook,
they clean.
You can beat on them.
Every once in awhile the cops come pull.
They're going to believe me.
Uh,
some dude with a wig and a black eye.
Those jokes,
that's a great bit.
And the jokes come at you before.
You know where he's going.
Yeah.
The cops come,
who are they going to believe me are some do with a wig?
And a black guy.
That's a brilliant joke.
But it's that economy of words and there's a,
there's a,
that's like a skill.
If when you see a comic and they have too many words before they get to the
punchline,
either that's a new joke and they're trying to figure out how to say it,
which I do when I have new jokes,
I'll oftentimes go back and listen to old recordings of a joke that I'm doing.
Like three months later where I've got it down,
I'll go back and listen to how I started doing it three months ago.
And it's embarrassing.
It's terrible because there's so many extra words in itself.
Meandering.
It's just,
yeah,
the,
so there's technique to everything,
man.
Everything.
But in martial arts,
the consequences of having poor technique or the the most devastating cause
you're gonna get hit or you Canadian strangled or are you going to get your arm
snapped?
Like all the technique in martial arts is super,
super critical.
It's everything.
Do you think there's people that could just focus on five basic principles of
like Jujitsu and just Merck and that's all they do,
but they do it so well.
They can just wait on it perfectly.
You,
there's a guy named John Donna her who has done an amazing job and training
these killers,
just incredible athletes who've been able to beat people with far more
experienced than them because John who was a,
a a philosophy major in college and just,
he's a brilliant man.
A true genius has figured out a way to cut to the chase and figure out what is
most important,
what am I trying to achieve and what are the barriers trying to achieve this.
And then he's figured out a way to apply that to his students.
And it teaches students in this way that cuts the learning curve down radically.
And because of that,
he's developed these guys like Gary Tonin or Gordon Ryan or Nicky Ryan.
He's like guys who have not been doing Jujitsu relatively,
haven't been doing Jujitsu near as long as their competitors,
but are far more effective.
Yup.
So they're seeing some of his stuff.
Yeah,
he's genius man.
He's genius.
But,
but it's that it's,
it's the analysis.
What it is is a,
uh,
superior intellect that applies that superior intellect to something where
people may not have been as focused.
And there's also a problem that you Jitsu where a lot of people just like to
roll.
They just liked to spar because it's fun.
You learn a couple techniques,
then you try to get each other.
Cause it's a,
it's a fun,
it's a fun thing to do,
but the best way to do it is to drill and the re the really best way to do it as
a drill with intent and,
and understanding of each piece.
Like a very detailed,
comprehensive understanding of each position.
And what's the danger of not having inside control.
What's the danger of not having the underhook with and,
and see,
that's what,
for me,
that's what I feel like some of the places where I've gone and done Jujitsu,
they're not explaining.
So it's hard for you to absorb because I think just based on my background,
I'm wanting to know the basics and the why's and the drills and I'm totally
comfortable just being in the drills,
just being in the drills to where it's hard for me to want to learn something
new because I know that I'm not doing what you told me before.
Good enough for me to say,
okay.
I feel like I'm doing that without having to consciously really try hard at it.
Yeah.
And I,
I love that about sport where you,
you're able to just drill and drill and drill until the subconscious absorbs it.
And it's like at that moment I feel like I've made a step.
Yeah.
And now now drop something else in and I call it selective cycling.
I cycle things in when I feel like I've absorbed something that I've already
worked on.
It's like that with students.
You know,
Andy said it before,
he goes a year end.
You tell me something.
Were you just now tell me it and I look at you and I'm like,
a year ago I was doing this right.
And you knew it.
And I'm like,
well yeah,
of course I knew it,
but it wasn't relevant.
You're ready now to know right now you're ready to know.
And I almost feel like it's better,
at least for some people.
For me,
I feel like it would be that way because I would always be thinking back to,
well,
why was I doing that?
Why or I,
deep down,
I know I'm not doing good enough.
Like I'm not doing an efficient enough.
Whereas sometimes I've gone with people in there like we just roll because
eventually you'll just start to realize why it's important and that there,
honestly,
the places where I've stopped going is,
is those places because I'm like,
I can't,
I don't feel like I learned that way.
The things that we do at 10th planet is,
um,
Eddie breaks things down into paths and paths where people escape and then pass.
When people counter,
like sometimes like you'll,
you'll have a path where you will pass someone's guard,
moving them out,
go for the arm bar,
they defend the arm bar,
then they wind up on top,
then they pass and then they go into like an arm triangle or some other
submission.
So the person who was initially attacking winds up being the person who gets
submitted and you'll do this path and drill this path and you,
you basically,
it's almost like a choreographed a sequence of events that will take place in
sparring.
Like where you'll catch yourself in an arm bar,
you defend that arm bar and then all of a sudden you find yourself inside
control and then you find yourself submitting someone with this very same
sequence of events.
And that just builds your understanding of the positions and understanding of
like what can take place from those positions.
Like there's certain arm bars that you can catch while someone's going for a
twister or,
or someone's in the truck or if someone's in these various positions and until
you're there you don't really know it.
So the two to do it in like a very clear path.
So all the warm ups that we do will be these,
these pathways.
Yeah.
And I think it's important to,
you know,
there's people that say they listen to me and the,
and they just say,
you know,
I just don't get it.
I,
for whatever reason I don't like,
I don't like with Dudley's talking about,
I get it.
Yeah.
I've gotten,
I've gotten goodness,
it's an ego thing.
I've gone to places I think sometimes,
but I've gone to places where for whatever reason I'm hearing the same thing,
but I,
it's easier to take it in even though it seems like it's the same information.
It seems like there's some teachers that are really good at teaching and there's
some teachers that have been taught how to teach and it comes across that way
and it's hard.
It's hard to soak it in.
Well,
it's also the personality of the people that are teaching you.
And sometimes you don't want to learn from somebody.
You don't like them,
you don't like the way they're talking.
Or maybe they're arrogant.
And maybe that that arrogance comes off as like you want to prove them wrong.
And so just listening.
Yeah.
I get it.
Well the last thing we should talk about is probably where we started this trip
grilling.
Cause you and I are both passionate about cooking food.
Yeah.
We eat what we kill.
Right?
Yeah.
And you were,
you are on a different grill path complete weren't you?
I mean I kept telling you like,
dude,
I don't know a lot about this trigger but man,
it's like changed my life.
Well I was doing things very hot.
Yup.
And uh,
I was uh,
I had a Yoder that has a direct heat element and the direct heat aspect of it
was a uws grilled greats they'd put down and he would turn up the flames very,
very,
very high.
And I would cook on these grill grades.
Did you put these grill marks on the uh,
on the meat?
It was drying out the meat though and until Chad a whiskey bent barbecue.
Yeah.
Chad war.
Chad Ward on the instrument Paolo until he explained it to me.
The idea of the reverse sear,
cooking things low and slow,
and then seeing them at the end.
I really didn't get it.
And then once I just started cooking like that,
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
You mean I get mad when I go to a restaurant,
a good restaurant and that they cook the steak.
Isn't that a bummer?
It's a bump.
Talked about that all the time,
dude.
What do we cook night one?
When Sharon and I flew in,
did we cook cowboys steaks?
Revise and revise and revise.
Yeah,
we ate those at the house.
You've got,
so you've got the new iron wood.
It's,
it's like,
it's not the highest end trigger.
It's the next one in line.
Yeah.
For someone buying one in the store.
Dude,
well I had an iron wood before and timberline,
excuse me,
a timberline before and they wanted to give me the ironwood because it's the
newest version with the,
um,
the,
and they had to,
they hadn't had the two motor,
they didn't have the timberline,
the new timberline out yet.
But you know what,
man,
if you're on a budget,
I mean,
it's phenomenal.
I have no complaints.
I have the six 50,
I had the timberline 1300 before,
but this iron would six fifties amazing.
It's so good.
And I love the APP.
One of the best things for me for triggers the APP and the fact that I can
adjust the temperature of the grill on my phone.
And then also I could find recipes.
Like I cooked lobster tails the other day and I got the recipe directly from my
phone.
And uh,
I went to the grocery store,
I got the ingredients based on that and I,
I,
I cooked it on,
on the trigger with Mike.
What did you tell me you cooked at?
I think you said you cooked something only to 25,
just so you could use a super smoke.
Well,
I've been doing that a lot with roasts.
Oh really?
Yeah,
I've been doing that a lot.
I really liked that super smoke,
man.
It just,
it does something to the,
I love that smoky flavor that you get everything.
It's one of the best things about pellet grills and I think I've had a lot of
pellet grills,
you know,
uh,
the triggers the best.
It's the best.
It's the best that maintaining temperature,
it gets to temperature better.
It's the easiest to work.
It does such stable too.
I've had some complicated ones where they,
it cooked good,
but it was like you had to like read the manual and figure out how to do things
and triggers a straightforward,
but the,
but pellet grills without a doubt are my favorite way to cook food because
you're just getting fire and wood.
There's no nonsense.
There's no charcoal.
Lighter fluid is no briquettes it's just wood and,
and fire.
It's appellate.
That's repetitive.
Yeah.
And then what they figured out how to do,
first of all,
it's so efficient.
The Traeger uses so little pellets.
Like I fill that hopper once I go,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10 cooks was just,
I mean,
it's a foot,
a foot deep of pellets and it takes forever to run.
Run through that.
We were eating those revise that night.
And we're like,
dude,
this is as good as your editors know.
Like I haven't gone anywhere.
I would say I need to know how this guy is doing this because it's better than
what I'm making at home.
No,
they were definitely as good as anything I've ever got ever.
Yeah.
And it's so easy to use and to do it at two 25 and I love the fact that trigger
has that probe and you can,
you will eat it on your phone.
The APP.
Yeah.
Harry is,
has his first apartment right now and I don't,
and actually it's a summer.
He's got a,
he's a,
he's in a research project,
which is pretty,
but
uh,
I don't think he realized that the school wasn't cooking food because he was in
his apartment one night and he sent a text to share in that said campus is
closed.
We can't get food there,
so we've got to do our own.
And he goes,
do you think dad could cook for us some nights?
And she's like,
you need to cook for him.
So I told them,
I said,
do you want me to do,
I forgot what I said.
We did a brisket,
said I'll cook a brisket for your guys.
Uh,
so I started it at night.
I literally woke up at three in the morning,
grab my phone next to my bed,
open it up,
told me that the brisket was at like one 59 I got up,
went outside,
put the brisket in a big foil Pan,
wrapped it all in there,
put in a little bit of juice,
sealed it all up,
bumped the temp up to two 75 put it back in the grill,
closed it,
and just set the alarm for when the brisket hit two oh four like set the alarm
on the APP.
So the next morning at 9:00 AM being,
it goes off the briskets at two Oh four I took it out,
set it in a Yeti and just left it in there until the guys came home after their
10 mile run for that day and just sliced it and it was ready to go.
Amazing.
It was perfect.
Yeah,
it's the perfect combination of technology.
Yama.
Shit.
I ruined on a fricking propane web.
Oh yeah.
Or charcoal grill.
Yeah.
I had a Kamado one of those ceramic grills,
which is great.
It's great until you use a pellet grill.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
my wife was like,
get rid of this stupid thing.
Like you don't even use it.
I'm like,
but it looks cool.
Well,
it's like people that say you need to learn how to start a fire with two sticks.
No.
Yeah,
I can do it.
But I also can buy a bic lighter,
the gas station when I'm filling up my car.
So I really know.
I mean,
look,
it's a good survival skill.
Yeah.
If you really do find yourself,
and I know some guys like to just bring like a Flint and some,
some,
uh,
I got it swaps there.
Some people,
Vaseline.
Schneider likes a shooter.
Traditional bow.
I don't get more power to them.
I don't get that.
But then other people say,
why shooting a bow and he can shoot a rifle,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
We're in that category,
dammit.
Yeah.
Idiots.
Well,
the argument for that is these damn deer,
there's an access tier.
I met some hunters this morning.
Real nice guys.
And one of the guys,
he got his first big game animal today with a rifle.
Um,
so they were there for half an hour and they shot a deer.
Yep.
We hunted for five days for me.
I struck out five days in a row until finally I connected on the sixth day with
a Beautiful Bach.
But we'll dude,
we're on.
We're on.
We're flashing on one,
one bar.
A battery.
I'm afraid of it.
Battery charger.
Wow.
Do you have a thing to plug in?
But do we have a plugin plugin close by us?
It's gotta be some well outlet here and figure that part out.
Just bail on this.
Um,
I don't see anything clear.
Quitters religious bail.
Dammit.
There's any power here.
Well,
see it,
dude,
this was awesome.
Hey my brother.
Listen,
it's always,
always a good time hanging with you.
I love hunting with you.
Thanks for [inaudible] me about the archery.
Hey,
the next time we see each other.
Do you know who are going to be introducing the archery?
Bowhunting.
Who?
Jocko Jocko is first bow hunt is going to be archery elk in Utah.
Oh,
do amazing.
We have an awesome camp.
This is,
that's going to be legit.
That's going to be legit.
Oh,
we'll be doing some podcasts from their phone.
Why don't you worry.
Yeah.
I'm wondering if he'll still act as tough and cool as he,
yeah,
he think he's going to keep it together.
I think you'll probably be pretty stoic and just listen.
Yeah guys.
And he's a good learner.
People at that position.
Yeah.
They know how to learn.
He's a black belt in Jujitsu to you don't you don't get to be a black belt
unless you're a good learner.
He might have to beat it into them,
but I don't think so.
I don't think so.
I think he's just going to listen.
Would it be fun if he like missed his first one?
The elk just school disaster where he was like where he thought he could just
tough it out.
I would like to see him get a fucking 10 ring.
That's what I want to say.
Yeah.
I want to see it.
An l dropped away.
My elk dropped it to hone where the step four steps and just tipped over.
That's what we all do this for you say it?
I say it.
Cam says it.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't know.
I it was uh,
it was a super fun,
I'm so thankful that that day that you couldn't go,
that I asked cam to go with me because that was the first time that we've hunted
together.
And I would say,
I mean we were both at Uaa for 12 years together,
never had hunted together and it was,
it was pretty cool.
Once you get in a situation where,
especially a hunting situation where it's,
it's life or death,
I mean for what you're pursuing,
the movements that you make and the choices you make,
they really define,
they do define you.
And whether people out there like me or don't like me or like cam or don't like
Cam.
All I can say is when we were in the moments that we are in,
that's the ultimate litmus test for me.
Like a hunting situation for me is a litmus test for a person.
For you.
I think it's someone that like actually goes into a real fight right from a,
it's a lot of things.
It's comedy.
Oh yeah.
I've gotten to become friends with someone that I've watched him on stage.
I'm like,
oh,
I can't be friends with you anymore.
Really?
Yes.
Terrible.
But then are there times where you're like,
this guy,
I don't really know,
but then when you see him,
you're like,
you know what,
like 100% he got my respect.
Oh yeah.
And that's where it was at.
You know,
I can,
I,
I'm,
I'm truly,
I'm truly respectful and I'm honest when I say that.
Yeah.
Like,
you know,
I wouldn't add cam on my podcast if I wouldn't have said that there was,
it was an eyeopening experience for me.
I had a very,
very good time with them and I think we both
kind of found a different,
different appreciation for each other.
He's an awesome guy.
I love him to death,
so it's so cool for me to see you guys become friends.
Yeah,
it really is.
It's amazing.
I think comedy and bow hunting have one thing in common is that it's so
difficult to get to that elite level.
Then once you meet someone,
it's like how many of you you,
how many are there?
I mean how many like legit elite bow hunters are there?
Are there even 500 on earth?
Oh my God,
it would be way smaller.
Same with comedy,
smaller comedy.
I think it's probably the same thing.
I mean I know I would offend people or people will be like,
what?
I'm not on that list,
but I think it's really small and,
and I'm talking on like not just a good level.
I'm talking on a level where if someone said,
listen dude,
you have,
you have like 10 cards to play in these cards.
Every card has to hit.
Who are the people on this card?
Yeah,
it's small man's Ma.
Is that fair to say?
Yes.
It's a hundred a hundred percent fair.
Yeah.
I think it's,
there's many things in life and there's a lot of different personalities within
those,
like people,
some people have different personalities,
some people get to the same place with a different path,
and sometimes it's abrasive.
Sometimes they're the fan favorite,
but in the end,
like the people that are within that realm,
it's like the big brother house.
There's people that people are rooting for,
and there's people that people,
you know,
or like,
I don't know how that guy got there.
It doesn't matter.
He's there.
Yeah.
It's an old expression game recognizes game.
Just leave it at that.
My brother loves cheers brother.
All right,
everybody.
Bye everybody.
See you.